good morning and welcome to safety ridge
on sunday
when you're president of the united
states there are lots of things you
think but can't say one of them might
well be hoping that vladimir putin was
no longer president of russia but just
how sensible was it for joe biden to
voice that yesterday his plea that this
man cannot remain in power during an
emotional address in warsaw yesterday
hangs heavy this morning we'll explore
the implications and the current
situation on the ground in ukraine
meanwhile closer to home there's an
extremely busy week of domestic politics
ahead with the white paper on schools
the energy security strategy and
continued fallout from a spring
statement that didn't quite land as
richie sunak would have hoped lots to
discuss with i guess this morning
in just a moment we'll be talking to the
education secretary nadim zahawi and
i'll get the view from labour as well
with shadow work and pension secretary
jonathan ashworth on the show
crucial as ever is it to hear voices
direct from ukraine so we'll be talking
live to the country's head of delegation
to the council of europe member of the
ukrainian parliament maria mezantsava
and someone who knows what it's like to
flee as a refugee is nimko ali she's the
government's independent advisor on
violence against women and girls i spoke
to her about ukraine afghanistan the
treatment of child q and more plus we'll
be joined by dame margaret beckett the
first woman to hold the great office of
foreign secretary who has just announced
her retirement from the house of commons
[Music]
hello well we'll be finding out the
government's vision for schools in the
england this week there'll be a white
paper setting out new plans to drive up
standards and that comes after two
incredibly difficult years for the
education sector during the pandemic
with continuing concerns over lost
learning and the impact on the most
vulnerable children so we're joined now
by the education education secretary
nadim zahawi thank you very much for
being on the programme this morning
we'll get to education in a minute but i
just want to start with ukraine and in
particular those comments by president
joe biden for god's sake this man cannot
remain in power
does the uk government also think that
putin has to go i think that's up to the
russian people
the russian people i think are pretty
fed up um with what is happening
in ukraine this illegal invasion the
destruction of their own livelihoods
their economy
is collapsing around them uh and i think
the russian people will decide uh the
fate of putin and his cronies the
important thing to remember is that
there is evidence that our war crimes
have been committed
in the ukraine targeting of civilian
areas in the ukraine and
you will know that the deputy prime
minister dominic raab has been working
with the international criminal court to
make sure that that evidence is well
documented well collected
so that those who commit war crimes know
that there will be a day of reckoning i
mean you're very clear aren't you in
saying that it's for the russian people
to decide who that president is
it's not helpful is it as common from uh
jay biden i mean u.s president's calling
for regime change doesn't always end
well well i think the white house has
been very clear
um after that uh speech which is a very
powerful speech by president biden
talking about contradicts what he said
on well they've been clear that actually
it is an illegal invasion of the ukraine
and that must end um and i think that's
what the president is talking about i
think it's right that it is for the
russian people to decide how they are
governed i suspect as i say to you many
of them will have
friends
indeed family
that are ukrainians and having innocent
ukrainians murdered by putin's regime
is not something that sits well with the
russian people either
so i think it's important to remember
that they will make decide that uh they
will make that decision ultimately so he
was wrong to say that
no i what i'm saying to you is the um
white house has been very clear on this
the president gave a very powerful
speech on this and i think um it's
both the united states and the united
kingdom agree that is up to the russian
people to decide uh who should be
governing them they would certainly do
well to have someone
that is democratic and understand their
wishes i suspect um the majority of
russians
see the invasion as illegal and want
this war to end
now there's been talk this week that
russia might be scaling back its
ambition in ukraine that the defense
ministry saying its main goal was the
liberation of the donbass region in the
east
what's your latest intelligence about
what is actually happening on the ground
in ukraine
well clearly the
russian military has miscalculated
i think
the
initial
um sort of shock and awe of taking the
whole of ukraine
has not worked for them the ukrainians
have fought like lions uh they've
defended their country uh they believe
in their freedom they believe in justice
and the rule of law and their democracy
which is why i think uh the russian
military find it much tougher and
they're losing uh tens of thousands of
innocent uh young men who've been sent
to the front line not knowing why
they're invading a neighboring country
that is democratic and i think uh
they're they're they're paying the price
and maybe a change of strategy then you
think well clearly if you look at the um
uh ministry of defense's um uh
assessment that we're putting out um
they're having real problems
now liz trust has told the sunday
telegraph today that sanctions on russia
should only come off after a full
ceasefire and withdrawal from ukraine so
do you think that's a condition of any
sort of peace deal is that what we're
starting to move towards
it has to be any peace deal has to take
into account the wish of the free
ukrainian people i also think president
zielinski is right about this that any
serious peace deal
has to be negotiated face to face
between president zielinski and putin
that is the only way putin is going to
be serious about this i think the only
thing
that the regime understands
is
the strength of the military response
from the ukrainian military and of
course the strength and resolve of the
ukrainian people so i think president
zielinski is absolutely right all this
stuff will not be taken seriously by him
or the ukrainian people unless putin's
prepared to sit down with him and just
to be clear then no sanctions coming off
until there's a full ceasefire and
withdrawal
absolutely right i think uh the
russian
illegal invasion has to end and the
russian army has to leave the ukraine
and it's up to the ukrainian people
they must be very much the ones who
decide what that piece looks like
now just to kind of take a step back for
a minute you know we've seen millions of
people displaced from ukraine families
children
you of course came to the uk
your family from assam usain's iraq when
you were a boy you've always said that
you were not refugees but immigrants but
at the same time you know you were a boy
you didn't speak the language
does it bring back i guess memories and
how do you feel some of those children
must be feeling you know you see them
moving across
continents being thrust into different
places very much so it's um
a combination of of anger um um
loss huge loss because you're ripped
away from
all those things that you held at deer
and and those sort of protective layers
of of family and
home
and you don't understand why this is
happening to you
and so i absolutely feel
that which is why
my department
has made preparations to take up two
hundred thousand ukrainian children into
our education system from early years to
primary to secondary of course to
colleges and universities and we will
deliver that we did it for the afghan
resettlement scheme uh we're doing it
with the hong kongers 104 000 have
applied to settle here as well how did
you feel as a sort of 11 year old boy
not speaking english
um fear
the first few weeks i
sat in the back of classroom i hid at
the back of the classroom because
children can be cruel um i tried to
string words together in my head the few
words i knew as i began to obviously
read and and write to try and make a
sentence to join in the subject matter
but when i'd
made that sentence the subject matter
had moved on so the early uh few weeks
my teachers thought i had learning
difficulties which is why our green
paper is so important um uh next week
but also our white paper as well because
my parents uh understood the value of
education my mother used to always say
it will unlock opportunities my son so
work hard and focus on education it's
only when i started to
think in the language that those
opportunities really unlocked for me
i want the system which is why the white
paper is so important to work for every
child to a strong school with a great
teacher
for every child in the right place at
the right time
to deliver that
the white paper i think will
go a long way towards that because that
has to be available for the children
whose parents don't have the wherewithal
or have no parents at all let's talk a
bit about that white paper what is the
big idea then
so the the big idea is learn from the
evidence we are about to announce our 10
000 academy so that's real scale i have
22 000 schools approximately in england
the evidence is that a family of schools
that is tightly um supported really well
managed in a strong performing and
underlying strong performing um
multi-academy trusts because some of
them um haven't performed as well but
the strong performing ones have
delivered outstanding outstanding
results for the children and so the
white paper will
essentially will be the road map towards
getting all schools into that strong
family of schools with some you know
really strong targets so at the moment
only two-thirds 65 percent
of primary school children finish
primary school with the ability to read
write and do maths
to a a good standard
we're going to raise that to 90 percent
on
secondary school we're going to move the
average in english language and maths
from 4.5 to 5. now that sounds
like not much of a an ambitious target
there's only 0.5 point movement but
actually it means all children um who
are
doing their gcses will have to improve
the lowest one-third and the higher
chance if a child falls behind in
english amounts what actually happens so
if a child falls behind i have the
national tutoring program which is part
of the five billion we are investing in
recovery uh teachers will actually be
able to identify what that is be able to
use the natural tutoring program
it in the past has been the privilege of
fortunate parents wealthier parents now
it's available to every child so my
message to families watching this at
home is
ask your school
are they participating in national
tutoring program it's a really important
program to help that recovery and of
course help us meet those targets and
you want a longer school day for every
for all schools so the average school
day is 32 and a half hours some schools
thousands of schools are 10 20 30
minutes
lower than that um so we want schools to
be so from 9 00 a.m till 3 30. by the
way if it's 20 minutes lower
than the 32 and a half hours um that is
the equivalent of two weeks
lost from the uh uh the the the
school um
two weeks loss of learning is a big loss
which is why i want every school to do
this i'd like them all to do it by the
end of this year but i know some of them
have logistical problems which is why
we've said by next year okay they should
achieve that now so you want all schools
to have this
not longer day necessarily but as a
certain amount of
hours and a day you want better teaching
a promise to intervene if children fall
behind
the schools have struggled haven't they
with years of effectively underfunding i
just want to show this uh graph that i
think we should bring up now this is the
funding gap between state and private
schools since the
conservatives entered power you can say
the change of funding sorry the change
of per-pupil funding so you can see that
the blue line is private schools that's
the fees that parents pay
per pupil and fights for private schools
the red line is state school spending
per pupil and this is the change per
pupil the dotted line 2010 when the
conservatives entered
power
if you're a parent looking at this what
do you think you would conclude about
how the conservatives prioritize state
school pupils
so you'll remember in 2009
uh that was the financial crash and the
crisis that
led to us having
to tighten our belts and of course
try and get the economy back on his feet
thank goodness we managed to do that
because then we got the pandemic where
we've had to spend 400 billion making
sure that people's jobs are protected
and of course businesses are protected
but if you look at the settlement i've
just got is an additional seven billion
uh by 2024 25 much of it front load
loaded by the way so four billion that
comes early it's effectively restoring
per pupil funding to 2010 levels you've
got a lost decade haven't you
effectively of
of growth in funding for comprehensive
schools and state school pupils but but
also
as i just explained we had to get
through uh the financial crisis on the
back collapsed state school
well but but the important thing is is
to continue that investment now and
deliver it's not just the seven billion
by the way i've got five billion for
recovery as well part of that is the
national tutoring program these are
important investments in school and of
course teachers have done a brilliant
job if you think of what they've had to
come through including of course dealing
with omicron 99.9 of schools are open
the viruses hasn't gone away um you know
we still have uh nine percent absence um
of teaching staff and support staff um
in schools so um i'm very conscious that
we have to keep continuing to support
the teaching profession okay the best
way to do that is the vaccination
program and of course we have the
booster uh and the announcement that we
will uh now go further with protecting
the most vulnerable with a fourth shot
um and of course making sure that we
keep supporting schools uh through both
local direct public you're
the pandemic which obviously had a
really very devastating impact on
schools it widened inequality as well
private schools saw a 12 percentage
point increase in a stars last year
comprehensive schools a 3.9 increase
you've said that closing schools looking
back was a mistake was cancelling exams
a mistake as well
so i think uh
the secretary of state then had very
little choice would you have done it
well once well
one when
you know the inquiry will look at uh the
decisions made to get the country
through the level would you have done it
we've already cancelled exams
i don't think he's had much choice
the truth is that the closure of schools
um when i reflect on that was a mistake
and i'm on record of saying that and i
will do everything in my power never
again to close schools and the prime
minister absolutely agrees with me
because the uh not just the learning
loss but actually the mental strain on
young people the anxiety if you look at
what the children's commissioner has
done on serving half a million children
they said actually they really wanted to
be back at school i was at totteridge
academy um last week and the children
said to me the worst thing that happened
to us is having to be at home and learn
at home i saw it for myself with my own
uh child so
i will do everything in my power to make
sure we don't do that and part of the
learning to live with covert is very
much around that but it's the teachers
who've done a brilliant job it's a
support staff in schools who've allowed
us to get to this position so we can
live with the virus closing schools was
a mistake
you've got more money for schools so by
implication there perhaps wasn't enough
uh previously we've talked about the
inequality gap
your predecessor was awarded a
knighthood gavin williamson what was
that for services to boris johnson's
leadership campaign or his record on
education so sophie i'm going to say
something to you which isn't universally
popular i know
but being in the department and you see
this on my lapel here it's t levels
um the skills white paper
and the skills bill which is about to
receive royal ascent
was gavin williamson's work when i was
in the department okay under the
threesome so he deserves the skills
skills was considered the cinderella
part of the department gavin
williamson's work on skills t levels the
lifelong learning entitlement will
transform the fortunes of young people
in our country who may not want to go to
university i think
for that alone he deserves that night
okay now we're expecting the government
to publish its plan for uh energy uh
next week with a push on renewables so
there's a bit of a debate over whether
to relax planning laws to allow more
onshore wind farms to be built now in 20
in 2012 you signed a letter opposing
onshore wind have you changed your mind
no i would say that if we are going to
make sure that
uh we carry the will of local people
whether it's onshore wind or nuclear we
have to learn
from how it's done well in other
countries and the way you do that is
making sure the local community
uh have a real say uh and what want
onshore wind if that's what they they
they want to have
but also we've seen great examples in
other countries where if they build a
nuclear power station within a certain
radius of that power station people get
free power so it's right to look at
innovation to make sure that we wean
ourselves off hydrocarbons we have to do
that and have to do it uh well
part of that is making sure that
we look after the will of the lord just
to clarify then so
do you
agree with the idea that planning laws
should be relaxed to allow more onshore
wind farms to be built only if
the local community supports having more
onshore wind i think that's the right
thing is there around cabinet about this
at the minute
no there is no rail because we have
collective responsibility in cabinet we
discuss things and when we agree
we take that
agreement seriously and we have
collective responsibility uh now energy
bills obviously are going through the
roof this is why we're looking at these
um innovations uh inflation forecaster
hit 8.7 the resolution foundation
saying that half a million children can
be pushed below the poverty line
rishi sunak is going to have to come up
with more support isn't he
so
we are today
in a global battle against inflation
literally um the the world is battling
this in the u.s in europe we are too
what does that mean
to the consumer your viewers when you're
in a global battle against inflation it
means the cost of
everything from your shopping basket to
your energy bills going up what rishi
did um is to say actually what has
worked is local government know who is
most vulnerable
so we've doubled the size of the how has
he done
he's done enough he's put 22 billion for
one year of help 9.1 billion of it for
energy and the rest of it is is things
like making sure that people on
universal credit
and the taper they actually keep more of
the money
do you think he has done enough then i
think he will continue to keep an eye on
this it's only right it's irresponsible
for me to say you know job done because
energy prices are volatile
inflation remains high
so it would be absolutely irresponsible
to say job done but what i would say to
you is putting 22 billion to work
after spending 400 billion in response
to the pandemic is the right thing to do
one billion through local government the
universal credit uh taper on friday the
national living wage will go up which
means a thousand pounds uh for those
additional uh a thousand pounds for
those most vulnerable so we have to
continue to keep an eye on this but i
think 22 billion in one year of help
when you've just spent 400 billion is
the right thing to do now i just want to
end by talking about prince william's
caribbean tour and there have been a few
controversial moments i think everyone
will remember the picture
of the fence and prince william the duke
and duchess of cambridge uh reaching out
to touch the hands of some of those
children
um we can see some of the videos of draw
there and now he has acknowledged
growing republican sentiment within the
commonwealth saying that the trip
brought into even sharper focused
questions about the past and the future
he and the duchess of cambridge he said
were committed to service and that for
us that's not telling people what to do
do you think this could be the beginning
of the end for the commonwealth
no i think it'll be the beginning of
strengthening the commonwealth because i
think actually what prince william
and i know
he believes
deeply in the commonwealth is right to
say that
people have to decide independently if
they want to be part of the commonwealth
family
and that
decision
will strengthen the commonwealth not
take away from it which is why i think
he's being
very wise and have chosen his worth
carefully okay thank you very much for
being on the programme today nadine
zahari there thank you
well let's get labour's uh take uh now
shall we we're joined by the shadow
working pension secretary jonathan
ashworth thank you very much for being
on the program today
mr ashworth hopefully yeah there you are
great um i just want to talk to you
first about the situation in ukraine if
i may
and joe biden the u.s president has said
that putin in his words cannot remain in
power
i mean no matter how horrific you know
the war crimes that russia has been
committing is it right for the u.s
president to be effectively calling for
regime change
well the united states us and the united
kingdom and our nicer allies have been
clear what we think about
the action that russia has taken in
ukraine
the labour party entirely supports uh
the work that we're doing
internationally in the nato alliance we
support what the united states is doing
this is why we want to go as far as far
as we possibly can on sanctions
on russia
i'll leave the comments that the
president united states has made to the
subject for the white house to
to to clarify i think they put out
comments about that but we have to do
all we can to impose the maximum
pressure on russia through sanctions
we've obviously pushed the government to
go further and faster but we also need
to do what we can to support the ukraine
with what assistance and and to listen
carefully to what ukraine are calling
for in terms of assistance and we need
to ensure that there's humanitarian
support as well particularly around
refugees and
and it's great that we can that the
british people have shown such
generosity in signing up to the refugee
uh program but but we still have too
much bureaucracy in place and we need to
do all we can to take to take the
refugees that we obviously ought to take
okay and we talked about the need to
step up assistance to do all we can and
but i think it's important to get into
specifics isn't it because the easy bit
is saying that we need to do everything
we can we need to look at what ukraine
is asking for and president zielinski
has called on european countries to do
more hasn't he so what specifically do
you think the uk can actually do in your
view
well we've obviously already offered uh
equipment uh we need to our defense
experts will want to consider carefully
other requests for that for equipment
and make a judgment about what is
appropriate
we in the labour party have supported
the government on that and will continue
to support the government in whatever
decisions that they need to take with
in that respect but we also need to do
more on the humanitarian side as well i
mean there is so much bureaucracy in
place which is prohibiting the
ability for british families to take to
taking refugees as they have been asked
to do and have signed up and are wanting
to do so there's a number of things
where we need to move further and faster
but there is no division between the
labour party and the people of ukraine
and the labour party and and our
commitment to nato and our commitment to
doing the right thing in this awful
conflict
okay um we just heard from the education
secretary there's lots going on
domestically as well with the course of
living emergency effectively rather than
a crisis that is know hitting the united
kingdom
um firstly just to clear something up
you
when rishi should act gave his a spring
statement and after he'd finished
unveiling that support there was a kind
of a loud voice from the labour benches
shouting is that it was that you
yes it was me and the reason that was me
is because i thought rishi sunap in what
was a incredibly in what is an
incredibly serious time we just talked
about ukraine
failed to rise to the moment failed to
deliver for the british people look as a
consequence of the decisions that rishi
sunak and his conservative mps have made
the state pension will be cut in real
terms by the biggest amount for 50 years
the tax burden is going to be the
highest since the 40s the collapsing
living standards the most dramatic since
the 50s later this week the universal
credit will be cut in real terms
disability benefits will be cut in real
terms and that means over a million
people pushed into poverty many
pensioners pushed into poverty five
hundred thousand children pushed into
absolute poverty and there'll be people
watching the show this morning who can't
who are struggling with their bills who
can't fill up their car whose cupboards
are bare whose fridges are empty whose
children are hungry and rishi sunak
thinks that's a price worth paying well
we in the labour party don't
is the problem though um
money effectively i don't think anyone
would disagree about the
the concern that you have expressed
there about how families aren't going to
cope you know in the months and years
ahead but you know you want more money
for pensioners more money for the nhs
after covered because time thomas call
for more defense bet spending obviously
more money to tackle the cost of living
emergency through energy bills through
benefits
and and i know that you're gonna we'll
start talking about the chancellor's you
know windfall because of increased tax
revenues but things are of course very
volatile as well i mean the cost of
borrowing for example has quadrupled in
the last year is it not important for
the government to also maintain some
fiscal discipline
well we should obviously have more room
for maneuver in this spring statement in
this mini budget but but rather than
acting in the interest of the british
people
he was playing games he was acting in
his own interest because he thinks by
offering an income tax cut in two years
that will help him politically with
conservative mps if there's a leadership
contest or that will fit the tory
election grade
i don't believe that putting 1.3 million
people into poverty because you're
imposing a very severe real terms cut to
universal credit you're imposing the
biggest cut to the pension in 50 years
is fair
government is about choices and he could
have taken a different set of choices he
could have imposed a windfall tax on
those monumental profits the gas and oil
companies have made and use that
windfall tax to help struggling families
and pensioners with their energy bills
he chose not to do that instead he's
imposed these very punishing tax rises
these very severe real terms cuts to the
pension and support like universal
credit and he's expecting people to be
grateful because two years down the road
he's saying that there's going to be an
income tax cut even though that income
tax cut nowhere near offsets the 15 tax
rises that he has imposed on the british
people 3 000 pounds extra per household
if you do if you do a rough and ready
calculation he is a tax rising
chancellor he is mr tax and it's the
british people who are paying the price
well it's pretty clear that richie sunak
has seen his most difficult set of
headlines this week and i think that
goes without saying
who would you prefer to face in an
election boris johnson or rishi sunak
yeah
you know something i mean i i i'm not i
don't care that rishi sunak is facing
difficult headlines i'm more concerned
about the difficult circumstances
british pensioners are facing the
difficult circumstances that families
often in work are facing with the cost
of living as i say not able to afford
their heating bills cutting back on hot
meals that's what pensioners tell me
that they're not using their oven
because they don't want they cannot
afford the bills associated with heating
their oven or for going hot showers
because they can't afford the bills
associated with running hot water that
is what concerns me that is what makes
me angry that for the f the biggest real
terms cut in the pension for 50 years
and rishi sunath thinks that's a price
worth paying if he gets bad headlines as
a consequence of that you know quite
rightly because he is he is
pushing people into poverty because he
thinks by being clever that allows him
to cut tax in a couple of years time
income tax ahead of a general election
that's not right it's not a price worth
paying
uh okay now um let's just move on
because i'm quite keen to talk to you a
little bit about kovich you're obviously
working pensions uh brief at the minute
but you were shadow house secretary
throughout the air pandemic
so just put that hat back on briefly
covert cases are rising uh we're seeing
and around 1 in 16 people thought to
have the virus
how worried should we be about that
well i always said that living with
covid is not the same as ignoring covid
but i also said that there'll come a
point where because of our advances in
vaccination because of our advances in
anti-viral medicines that would be able
to move away from the restrictions that
sadly had to be in place uh
two years ago i think when you look at
where the infection rates appear to be
higher again some of the cities like
birmingham and leeds their second dose
rates and vaccinations are still in the
sort of 70 region so we've still got
further to go on vaccination it is not
job done on vaccination so i'd really
encourage the government to put in place
more support at a local level to drive
up those vaccination rates the second
thing of course is i remember before we
went into lockdown i went into downing
street to meet boris johnson and chris
whittie and dominic cummings and others
had separate meetings as well with matt
hancock to discuss the upcoming
legislation that would impose these very
severe restrictions we supported those
restrictions in the national interest
but we also said that people would need
economic support and from those
negotiations came an agreement that
statutory sick pay would be paid from
day one okay that day one saturday
sickbay has now been stopped well if
people are getting ill they will need
sick play from day one so i would urge
the government to reintroduce statutory
sick pay from a1
um we have run out of time but just to
quickly ask you uh your thoughts uh
after the duke and duchess of
cambridge's caribbean tour prince
william acknowledged growing republican
sentiment saying it's brought into even
sharper focus questions about the past
and the future
and he's not about telling people what
to do do you think this could be the end
of the commonwealth
no i i don't think the commonwealth will
and i think the commonwealth will enjoy
but obviously individual nations will
always make their own judgments and come
to their own decisions about their
membership of the commonwealth but i'm
i'm i feel i'm absolutely convinced that
the commonwealth will survive and will
endure and uh and
and and that's for the good
okay thank you very much for being on
the program today jonathan ashworth from
labour
to ukraine now and the city of lev for
weeks a gateway to the west for fleeing
refugees has been hit by several large
explosions yesterday but that comes as
moscow says its main goal is focusing on
areas in the east as it tries to secure
the donbass region so what is actually
going on in ukraine we can try and get a
sense of the situation on the ground i'm
pleased to say we are now joined
live from western ukraine by the head of
the ukrainian delegation to the council
of europe the mp maria mesan saver thank
you so much for being with us i can see
that you're in a car and so we'll just
cross our fingers and hope uh that the
signal stays okay and can you just give
us a sense about
excellent
can you just give us a sense about the
situation where you are
yes so we uh as um
you've received us very well very well
in a very high level in uk quite
recently and you know we think that
mps specifically women
have to be joining the diplomatic
missions because as
uk citizens know
men from 18 to 60 are not allowed to
leave the country with few exceptions
of this rule
which was the decision of
the
at the highest level taken and voted and
supported by the parliament
at the moment we've we are in the in the
regions
which we represented we are traveling
across the country as well a couple of
days ago we've had another very
important meeting in kiev voting on more
than 20 laws which are linked to social
life economy
supporting of business medical sphere
and of course security and defense uh
currently um
as the governor and the city mayor of
levith the city which you've mentioned
located in the very far west mentioned
rightly yesterday there is no more
secure place in ukraine so you know when
we are being asked are you safe right
now the safety is quite uh can be
temporary
for the moment we still face
very
harsh difficulties with securing the
humanitarian corridors and that's
how we are trying to raise this uh issue
across the globe so that the
international red cross unhcr and other
international organizations dealing with
human rights and have an actual mandate
for these green corridors would play a
better and more decisive role and we
salute the efforts of the minister
of the temporary occupied territories
she's doing a great job and more than
seven thousand people are being rescued
every day so let's say 90 percent of the
agreed corridors do work uh we have some
shortages in terms of
access to um some smaller cities and uh
one of the hero cities which is of
course mariupol becoming second aleppo
or a symbol of the uh of this um
glorious fight of ukrainian nation
against russian invasion russian
occupation russian aggression but there
are many more
of such marijuanas which are the smaller
okay small smaller cities next to the uh
for instance my home city harkev the the
uh in a far in the east uh which is uh
just two hours or so sorry 40 minutes
away from the russian border the city of
izum which is which is translated as a
raisin or the city of bhagavad-gita uh
and other ones we are trying to do our
best so that our volunteer groups which
are operating on the ground can reach
out to the people to deliver food
medicine and water what i have to
mention right now that twice already
during this week russian soldiers shoot
in the civilians who were queuing next
to the post office in harke and next to
the hospital uh city hospital to receive
humanitarian aid this is a complete
disaster we have
we have more than 80 people who died and
many more injured this is just an
absolute fact of a war crime against
ukrainian civilian population this is
definitely not soldiers against soldiers
this is something which is going beyond
the normal understanding understanding
of war conducts of any point therefore
the
prosecutor general office human rights
organizations are recording these cases
and it's very important to do it right
now so that they're not lost and the
justice will prevail
once we win this war
it's so so um you know heart-wrenching
to hear you talk about incidents like
that you know the shooting of people as
they
queue for
supplies and you've also
in your work going around talking to
different countries in their parliaments
you've spoken out about about what's
happening to women and you said that
women have been raped and hanged in
ukraine
oh i think we may have lost you but
hopefully we've got you um i'm with you
coming in yeah what um
what is happening to ukrainian women
there is uh one case which was very uh
widely discussed recently because it's
been recorded and uh proceeded with the
uh general uh the prosecutor's office
and we are not going into details but
it's
quite a scary uh
scary scene when
a civilian was shot that in his house in
a small town next to kiev uh his wife
was
i'm sorry but i have to say it raped
several times in front of her underage
child and this is something which
which is absolutely unaccepted in terms
of you know
talking about it public because there
are many more victims rather than just
this one case which has been made public
by the prosecutor general and of course
we are expecting many more of them which
will be public once victims will be
ready to talk about them so we can we
can bring them on that really
made um a huge let's say uh wave
information wave in the in the media
recently during this
week interviewed by many journalists and
we will definitely not be silent about
it because the
during this
the war itself is violence
uh when the violence is sexual uh when
the violence is
just a horror when you know what what
would be was this with this child who
witnessed once uh
uh the mom was raped just in front of
him or her that's that's just terrible
that's why you know when we've been
talking to boring johnson when we've
been talking to your home office
we've been talking to mps of uk we've
also raised this issue that this
aftermath which we are dealing with
right now the aftermath of war has to be
taken very cautiously very seriously and
to um take into account the uk
experience and the experience of other
countries uh which can help us in
dealing with psychologists uh and and
help to help help these people to
actually
leave over
this these cases to to keep going
afterwards to keep living to
still be living in
in in the normality of this world and
not this life that's what we have to do
right now but of course justice has to
has to prevail that's why these cases
are taken very seriously and that we are
very thankful for the prosecutor general
who is also from hierarchy of cities
she's a lady herself and she takes it
takes it very very very harsh and very
strong and recently she signed a
memorandum with
two eu countries to proceed with such
cases and to exchange the information
i'm sure uk would join this working
group
thank you so i know it's so hard to talk
about these um things but it is so
important to give a voice to what is
happening so we absolutely absolutely um
we don't have long left but just a quick
thought from you on the hope of any
peace deal it must be difficult for
ukrainians after
going through what you have to imagine
striking any kind of agreement with
russia but do you think one might
actually happen
president zielenski since day one in his
office always spoke about fair peace and
was always ready for direct peaceful
negotiations another part is that we've
witnessed for more than eight years of
the russian aggression uh where the
negotiations were done in trilateral
content group b
between the representatives of donbass
ukraine mediated by oac that russia is
never ready for a fair peace talks and
you know when we are remembering the
first round second round in belarus
during this time my home city was
bombarded what kind of approach to
peaceful negotiations is that so we uh
as ukraine as a state always rely on
international law international
humanitarian law we keep it up every
time nevertheless the
when the aggressor is trying to you know
twist it over and use
absolute absolutely um you know
terrible it means um
offers like you know let's do green
corridors to the occupied territories of
ukraine to crimea to donbass let's move
people to belarus or russia let's make
let's take their passports away et
cetera and you know this this this
casualties which are happening which are
now being recorded
there are there are no means for them to
get to get away with it anymore it's
been the the
the the world was half blind through
this eight years of war but i think now
it's the time when when we all have to
press russia as a collective west as a
collective international society to be
responsible for the actions that they
for the brutality uh which are
which they are conducting right now so
we do believe in peace but only based on
international law and a peace which is a
fair piece
okay thank you so much for being on the
program we really value the voices out
of ukraine so we appreciate your time
today thank you very much
well some tough um listening there about
violence against women and girls being
perpetrated
in ukraine and staying on that as a
theme the government's independent
adviser on violence against women and
girls says that the uk
and the u.s cut and run from afghanistan
calling the country's handling of the
situation actually terrible well i sat
down this week with nimko ali and she
said that she was also worried about
safeguarding issues around ukrainian
refugees arriving into the united
kingdom we spoke about the treatment of
child q and racism in the met police
along with allegations that she faced
about time she spent in downing street
while londa was on london was under tier
three coveted restrictions let's have a
listen
i just want to talk
initially about ukraine and it feels
like always in war you see women and
girls
being the victims yeah we spoke to the
ukrainian deputy prime minister on the
programme last week and she was saying
she'd heard horrible stories about women
being raped for hours and they're
murdered so how concerned are you about
what's happening to women and girls in
ukraine i'm very much concerned i think
we all ultimately always think that war
is about guns and bombs but ultimately
it's about women's bodies so we are
hearing um
stories of human trafficking on on on
the borders but ultimately i think rape
in war is a horrific thing and something
that we need to be aware of you
mentioned there about trafficking sex
trafficking on the borders in poland
what kind of things are you hearing and
how worried are you about what's
happening um you know what the whole
thing is are the patriarchy and those
that want to be able to pry on women and
vulnerable children where we will always
do it to during a um a traumatic
incident such as this a lot of the stuff
is antidote at the moment but they're
about but there are stories of girls
going missing and this is the thing it's
like it's it's it's it's a loss it's a
large-scale
move people and traffickers and those
that want to exploit young people are
going to be there and of course these
are people who are at their most
vulnerable they just fled a war zone 100
and just looking for safety and i think
it's easy for women and girls to be
taken in by traffickers i think we i
think there's there's a broader
conversation that we need to have about
the sex industry and actually how women
and girls are lured into that kind of
conversations because across europe
there's not the conversation that we
need to be having which is about ending
demand and actually we're really looking
at the sex industry as a part of the
valentine's women and girls kind of
framework as opposed to some kind of
business essentially so the uk is
obviously preparing for ukrainian
refugees to start coming here through
the friends and family scheme through
the homes for ukraine scheme
how much support do you think needs to
be in place for
women and girls who have obviously been
through this traumatic experience but
also may be very vulnerable themselves i
think we have to take a closer look and
i think the government is going to
do everything he can in order to be able
to support and women and girls but i
think coming back to the question about
um human trafficking and the feeding
into the second the sex industry i think
that's something that we have to be
aware of and it's not a conversation
that is readily had in the uk within the
kind of broader mainstream media i think
we kind of um
sensationalize it as something that like
you know out of a choice or a job but i
do think actually that there is a
massive problem and we will see that
through the sex industry and that abuse
that women fall into as a result of that
so is that something that you're
actively pushing in your advisory role
then looking at the sex industry here
well it's something that i was
very much keen on talking about when we
did the consultation the fact that i
don't actually think that prostitution
is a choice i don't actually see as
employment i see it as a form of
violence against women and girls and
some people think that's a relic
view to have but i think that's a view
that a lot of young women are having at
the moment so i would be i would welcome
us specifically within the home office
or anywhere else where within the
criminal justice system we're really
looking at the sex industry um as a form
of harm to women and girls and and
talking again about the um ukrainian
women
how much of a concern is it for you and
that you know we are getting this um
influx of refugees who are at the most
vulnerable into people's homes is there
a safeguarding issue there there is
definitely a safeguarding issue i don't
think we're necessarily doing as much as
that we would have done for um syrian or
afghan refugees because there's this
kind of idea the fact that because
they're europeans and they'll be a lot
safer in terms of mixing with westerners
um and i just need to i think within
that kind of con and when that kind of
concept is again we've seen um again and
again that those that want to take
advantage of vulnerable people will use
this opportunity where people are
looking for safety in order to abuse
them so i think we have to be very
unconscious of the fact that there are
going to be some people who don't
necessarily have the best intentions
when they talk about taking refugees in
there's a speed issue isn't there like
getting people here quickly getting them
into housing quickly but also doing the
necessary checks are you worried that
the checks might fall
by the wayside slightly i think because
we're having these conversations i think
that checks will happen but because it's
the kind of the um less rigid nature of
the refugee scheme so when people are
coming in from overseas in like whether
it's the iraqis the afghanistan or
somali such as myself i think there was
a lot more um scrutiny and i think there
were
there was a lot more safeguarding that
was in there because we understood that
a lot of these people couldn't speak the
language and would find it hard to
integrate and mix so i think we need to
be wary and not be too flippant about
the fact that just because they're
european and refugees that they're not
going to be as vulnerable as any other
refugees essentially you talk though
about your own background yeah and you
came to the uk as a refugee didn't you i
did at the age of seven and i said that
before that i think london has a very
special place in the world where the
fact that there are a lot of people that
are very much conscious of what the
ukrainians are going through either the
somalilanders myself and the syrians the
sudanese so there's a lot of people who
actually understand the realities of war
which is quite horrific
what i know it's everyone's different
aren't they but you know there's a
seven-year-old refugee coming here yeah
what kind of thing do you think
seven-year-old ukrainian girls are gonna
be thinking if they are arriving in the
uk i think that space of just like being
home so one of the things i was lucky
about was i'd lived in the uk prior to
me coming back so i think that sense of
um just peace and safety and you really
can't put a price on the ability of
actually to be able to sleep at night
and not have bombs going off and it is a
triggering thing seeing young um well
again i bring it back to the whole point
i know we're looking at ukraine at the
moment but there are wars still going on
in syria there's things happening in
afghanistan and other places and
children around the world are scared and
i think that is something that we
shouldn't take for granted you mentioned
afghanistan and how much of a duty do
you think we have to afghanistan given
this country's role in the war there i
think we have i think we have a massive
duty i think we should be embarrassed in
the way that we've actually dealt with
things and for me again as a muslim
brown girl i was like you know the
inhumanity that the way that women are
being treated and we're completely
disregarding the the lives of afghani
girls is actually really really
depressing yeah why do you think we
should be embarrassed
because the whole point is that we
actually just can't run i think um i
think nate i think the big um kind of
countries have a role to play and this
idea the fact that we can reason and
legitimize the taliban who are people
actually you know men who hate women
it's actually quite wild in my um
thinking and i say that as somebody who
deals with men who are consistently
trying to roll back the rights that
women have um the taliban don't care
about women and i think we should make
that clear and i think we should be
doing and we should be doing as much as
we can in order to be able to support a
real legitimate um like you know what's
what i'm looking for a legitimate
alternative to a taliban essentially
when you say we cut and run who do you
mean by we i mean
but i speak i i speak as a former child
refugee and as a feminism activist and
saying this but i think that both the uk
and the us were actually
like terrible in the way that they had
um that they handled afghanistan i'm
just going to bring it to the uk because
i think it's interesting the point
you're making about race um
it's a very different issue but still in
a form of violence against women and
girls with what happened with child q
and this was the 15 year old girl who
was in the uk in london pulled out of an
exam and stripped search while on her
period by um the police while the
teachers were outside the room because
she was suspected of having cannabis
which there was no drugs found on her
what's your reaction to that story i
mean i personally found it incredibly
shocking what was your reaction i know
it's an ongoing case and it's something
that is that should horrify us all and i
think the idea of a child being stripped
so to be they female or male should be
something that we shouldn't be able to
tolerate in this country and it said i
think in some of the reports afterwards
a safeguarding report said that racism
was likely to be a factor in that do you
know what it's it's sad that racism is
like this um i remember when the race
report came out and a lot of people
wanted me to kind of comment on that
like this country is one of the most
tolerant countries in europe but is
there more for us to do yes there is and
i think um kobe has actually really
brought out a lot of um kind of mcd and
unrest within people as well and i've
kind of experienced that in the last two
years that i like you know really
horrific
experience of racism which which i never
thought about the uk could be capable of
ultimately we have to talk about the
metropolitan police and institutional
racism you talked about the police there
and the racism but also for sexism and
obviously the murder of sir by the
serving police officer really shone a
light on sexism within the mat and i
just want to read some of the messages
that these were exchanged by officers at
chang cross police force they were
exposed by a report by the police
watchdog last month
i would have to rape you if i was single
i would happily chloroform you you ever
slap your missus it makes them love you
more seriously since i did that she
won't leave me alone
do you think there is a misogyny 100 i
think we have i think there's misogyny
like you know across this country at the
moment this one and there are things
that we're not talking about and
ultimately i think that again it's about
the whole conversation talking about
prostitution being seen as work when
you're actually paying for a woman's
human rights and liberty to be able to
have sex with you or not and access to
porn there's there's a lot of things
that have actually been that have gone
um unchecked and kind of corroded the
way that we have a social contract and i
said on a day-to-day basis i think the
social contract between men and women in
this country is kind of broken and we
are completely living on two different
planets sometimes boris johnson said
this week the basic facts of biology are
important do you think he's on the same
side of the debate as you are yeah i
think any i think anybody that
understands basic biology understands
that which side we're on when i'm not
here to say that you know that i don't
believe that trans people should have
rights i fundamentally and 100 to you
i've shared platforms way before anybody
else did with trans women and i
completely understand how the law has to
work when it thinks about fgm and all
these other kind of things these
conversations and i will fundamentally
support trans people but i don't think
that should actually take away the the
rights that women are still fighting for
i guess others would argue that trans
women are also women and are also at
risk
but but the reality is that trans women
are being murdered by men so they're
like like the people that are killing
trans women are the same people that are
killing women so we're on the same side
in terms of ending violence against
women and girls and i do think and i do
and i do support um the the protection
of trans women but what i don't support
is this idea that the fact that
feminists like me and and and women who
are fighting for biological women or
issues that biological women are facing
are the enemy we are not the enemy their
enemies male violence and those things
have to change there are reports that
you were in a child care bubble with the
prime minister and his wife over
christmas 2020 and this of course was at
a time when london was under tier three
restrictions now at the time you tweeted
to say i've had two days of racist and
disgusting tweets because a politics
fraud a twitter account chose to tag me
in an untrue story no i did not break
any rules so this is your chance to
clear up what exactly
happened i think that's i think that
tweet said it all um the fact that i
didn't break any rules and what was
really interesting was that the number
of people who understood that i didn't
break any rules that would um send me
private messages but not say anything
publicly with the kind of hateful things
i was getting so yeah so you were in a
childhood bubble which was allowed at
the time with the prime minister and
carrie is that like no rules were broken
it's one of the kind of things and i
think it's like the the um the whole
point is that's the main thing that no
rules were broken so but i think we're
kind of trivializing the fact that we're
talking about like you know refugees
were talking about trans rights and
everything else like that i think
something that was legal that happened
in 2020 should not necessarily be the
main bit of news today did you visit the
number 11 flat at any other time during
lockdown restrictions and have you been
contacted by the met police and their
inquiries
okay ali uh there now a quick reminder
our weekly podcast is back so if you
scan the qr code on your screen right
now you can find the sophie ridge on
sunday podcast and subscribe so that
it's in your feed
every week uh there'll be highlights of
the interviews on the podcast bit of
pace match analysis from me and the team
and hopefully some insight into how we
put the programme together so you can
find it and subscribe wherever you
usually get your podcast just search for
sophie ridge on sunday and you should
find it there available later today
now it's safe to say that foreign
affairs are very much at the top of the
political agenda right now and day
margaret beckham was the first woman to
hold the great office of state of
foreign secretary she's also held
several other cabinet posts and she's
been both deputy leader and acting
leader of the labour party one day
margaret is now retiring from frontline
politics as an mp she held the seat of
derby south since
1983 but she was first elected to
lincoln actually back in 1974 and i'm
very pleased to say she joins us now
from derby it's fitting you're from
derby of course because you've always
taken your role as constituency mp so
seriously um i want to talk to you about
ukraine but just first i thought i'd get
your reaction to what new kia ali said
in that interview there about
afghanistan um the uk and the us just
cut and run she said i speak as a former
child refugee and as a feminist and
activist but i think that both the uk
and the us were actually terrible in the
way they handled afghanistan i mean you
obviously visited the countries when
you're a foreign secretary
do you think we cut and run
i i can understand that that is her view
um i don't think anybody would argue
that the exit from afghanistan was
handled well
um there seemed to be a lot of questions
and there are a number of inquiries
going on
um into exactly what happened and why it
happened like that um but it does feel
very much as if not enough thought was
given
either to how the
um leaving of afghanistan would be
handled or indeed
as to how we can do more to to help and
safeguard what we're left behind
yes it's important and not to take our
eye off afghanistan while of course the
situation in ukraine remains what it is
as well um president biden yesterday
sounded an awful lot like he was calling
for regime change in russia when he said
that putin cannot remain in power
was he right to say what he did
i rather like what we've seen in joe
biden i know that he gets a lot of
criticism but he strikes me as being
somebody who has strong feelings and is
inclined to then just voice them
um
and you know
maybe we don't get quite enough of that
um sincerity and and uh reaction
sometimes from people in our political
world
i'm sure that
his staff and the people around him are
right to say america's not calling for
regime change
but equally i think many people will
sympathize with the sentiments
that led him to say what he did
do you think that's something that
you've seen change in politics then in
the years you've been there people
speaking a little bit less directly i
suppose i'm not sure it's changed i just
think that joe biden is is
more than most of us
a man who has
strong feelings and emotions and is
inclined to
say what he feels
it's difficult isn't it too for the west
to try and work out the right reaction
to the war in ukraine you see these
horrific war crimes being
committed but of course there is
concerns uh from the west about what
escalation would mean and the
consequences of that escalation
do you think that the uk and it's got it
just about right in the sanctions that
it's imposed supplying defensive weapons
but of course stopping short of
further escalation i suppose
i think it's a very difficult balance to
strike we are right of course to do
everything we can to support ukraine but
sometimes i hear people um saying oh you
know we're not doing enough and that
that may be right maybe there's more we
can do
but um
as if
uh okay let's send troops in it and i
kind of think are you really advocating
a war between nato and russia
because the idea that that would be
better
uh i i do find quite worrying
it's horrendous the situation in ukraine
and we have to do everything we can to
help
but to be drawn into a pan-european war
i don't think anybody would thank us
we heard from a ukrainian mp earlier on
the programme and she said that she felt
like people have been half-blind to what
has been happening with russia and
ukraine in previous years do you think
the west has previously taken its eye
off the ball with vladimir putin and
russia
i think there's been a perfectly natural
wish on everybody's part i mean the
whole gorbachev thing turned people's
approach towards russia
and people hoped that russia would more
and more come into the sort of
what you might call the mainstream of of
political life relationships between
countries and so on
but i'm i'm very mindful at any time
this past oh i don't know 10 20 years
if you talk to people in eastern europe
or rather perhaps if you listened to
people in eastern europe who had
experience of being under russian rule
they never had
um this sanguine approach they were
always
worried suspicious looking over their
shoulder saying you know russia hasn't
really changed you know
um
there are people in the baltic states
who will not be remotely surprised i
suspect at what has happened in ukraine
and who do see themselves if russia got
its way as being next in line and in
that sense i think there's been
something of a of a divide
where
the rest of us who haven't had that
experience
have been inclined to want to see the
best and and hope for things to change
for the better in russia but people
who've lived under russia rule have
always been much more wary and i'm
afraid it now seems to me that we should
have listened more to them at the time
and as you say i think listening is
perhaps the key word isn't it rather
than talking as you said
now you've announced that you're going
to be retiring as a member of parliament
you were 40 years at the mp for derby
south the first female foreign secretary
are there any specific memories that
you're always going to keep from your
time in the house of commons oh lots
too many
to go into
i think one of the things that i would
say though is
um
when i was first elected
this is a gross shorthand but roughly
speaking if somebody said there was a
photocall for all women mps you only had
to look round and you had
an idea whether we were all there or not
um
now i mean you know um it's it's not
remotely like that and indeed there was
a turning point when we used to have a
special section in the members cloakroom
just for the ladies
um and i think it was after the 87
general election that i came back and my
peg had moved i was like
oh well there are so many of you ladies
now that we've had to make it
alphabetical so
there are lots and lots of um
different memories most of them good
most of them good is that i think that
is that's nice i love the fact that they
had to make it alphabetical after that
election you're also of course labour's
first female leader when you appointed
acting leader in 1997
you've said since um that you know the
reason the party's never elected a
elected or female leader is because it
was just never was the right person at
the right time
but you know come on the labour party
was founded in 1900 you really think
it's never been the right time for a
female leader
i just think what people don't realize
who aren't practitioners in politics is
how much luck there is in politics
i mean
let's take the classic example margaret
thatcher margaret thatcher would never
have been the leader of the conservative
party if ted heath hadn't really really
offended so many people and upset them
so much they were prepared to have
anybody as long as it wasn't ted heath
and she got the credit for being willing
to stand against him if one of the men
had stood against him
then she wouldn't have been the leader
of the party there's a huge amount of
luck and personally by the way my view
is the first woman prime minister should
have been barbara castle she would have
been an absolute star
um but it was never
quite the right time and so on so
unless i say
gen this happens at every level uh local
council level parliamentary selections
and so on there is an enormous amount of
luck in politics
and the luck hasn't worked out
so far for one of our female colleagues
it will
just finally is there anything that
you're particularly looking forward to
doing more of in your retirement i mean
i know you're a keen
caravanner i think and people always
remember those sort of images of you on
your caravan holidays as what are you
looking forward to doing more of
well we had to give up our caravan about
a year ago because of my husband's
health
um and i'm thinking about whether or not
to try and get a motor car around but
there's a space thing about it that's
that's all
um
but
uh
i haven't quite settled into what i
would do in retirement yet because i
hadn't envisaged it without him
so difficult and i'm going to leave you
there and i know that he was someone who
of course so many people were very fond
of seeing around parliament and i know
i've spoken to you previously about what
a wonderful man he was as well so you
know
my best wishes to you and thank you very
much for being on the show
day margaret there well that is it for
this week's uh sophie ridge on sunday
some very powerful uh interviews on the
show at this week and in a moment we'll
be talking through some of those
interviews with our deputy political
editor sam coates thank you
[Music]
you